all these false stories i mean this kid
comes from a family with family members
of multiple races
they did a deep dive on all of his
social media i mean they did a
colonoscopic
kind of review of his social media and
they found no connections of any form of
racism of any kind
no connections to militia of any kind no
connections to anybody like that of any
kind
no statements like that at any time all
they had was that he had once gone to a
trump rally
that was their sole basis the oh you
went he went to a trump rally
like exactly and he's a gun supporter
and he's a police military supporter and
that was it but they all they just did
that most the media ran with these false
allegations the stream of false
to this day they continue to tell false
stories the prosecutors continue to lie
about them
using court proceedings to get away with
the lie the kid's the most innocent
defendant i've ever represented
ever been involved with but the case
goes far past him if he gets convicted
uh self-defense is dead in america
all right so election trump okay
maybe my youtube channel is here maybe
not either way i'll be just fine thanks
to locals
uh what else is on your mind right now
on the legal front
well i think the biggest issue that
biggest case that i have coming up
is going to be the kyle rittenhouse case
because this is the right of
self-defense which to me the second
amendment is not so much about guns it's
about the right of self-defense
the most effective means of self-defense
is to have access to
the method of self-defense being a gun
ownership but what the second
amendment's really about is your right
to defend yourself
against either the state or other
citizens in order to secure your
property and your liberty
and the there's probably no more pure
act of self-defense than what kyle
rittenhouse did
and the fact they're trying to put him
in prison for life
is one of the greatest risks and threats
to self-defense in american legal
history
and that trial is coming up this
november and it was being cheered on
by the mainstream media as if he was a
white supremacist of course
there's no evidence that he's a white
supremacist but could you just back up
and
i showed the video on the show but for
people that don't really remember the
case this was in kenosha
can you just explain to people what
happened and actually what he's charged
with
sure so you know kyle rittenhouse is a
son of a working class nurse
uh single mom uh who to give you an idea
of who he is
he goes back he went back and forth when
he was young to wanting to do some sort
of military or police work or be a nurse
he's a guy who sees himself as a
protector as someone who rushes into a
traumatic situation
and tries to heal the situation so
that's who he is by personality that's
who he is by biography
and that's by the way what he said in
videos that day right before that that's
why he was there he was not there to
hunt anyone down or shoot anybody he was
there to help
meaning if people were being assaulted
yeah completely and while people saw the
gunning that he had for self-defense and
for the defense of property and others
what he also had on him was a bunch of
nursing equipment and nursing materials
to help people so what happened in
kenosha was after there was sort of a
misrepresentation of what happened in
the blake case
where they thought the police officer
did something different than what was
actually the case as it ultimately
turned out
so it was one of those sort of fake blm
narratives that all of a sudden they
started having riots they started
burning down the city kenosha's a
working-class town on the border of
of illinois and was in between milwaukee
and illinois
uh they were burning down businesses and
what people a lot of people don't know
is most businesses don't have arson
insurance
or particularly riot insurance riots
often an exception under their insurance
policies
so these were businesses that were small
businesses that were wiped out forever
no means of recompense and this was
happening day
after day night after night the governor
was letting
the democratic governor was letting it
happen frankly not calling in the
national guard
so a bunch of local people in the
community went out that night and said
let's protect people
and what kyle did was let's protect
people and i'm going to be able to try
to help people who get hurt
and so he goes out there and that night
the first person that there's a
he gets different attacks on him and
finally he gets this one guy who chases
him down
throwing things at him people from our
are firing guns behind him
there's video of all of this by the way
all of it exactly grabs the gun
tries to pull the gun away from him he
ends up getting shot by the way this guy
was suicidal
he he was he had been previously
convicted of a bunch of horrendous
crimes
he had tried to kill himself repeatedly
just been let out of a mental
institution so that was the mindset of
this individual who attacked him
and he put things into motion i think if
that guy had got that gun that night
there'd be a lot of other people dead
because he's got a mass shooter kind of
psychology
so uh so kyle probably saved a lot of
other people's lives that night just by
defending himself in that situation then
kyle's trying to run away trying to run
towards police when he gets chased by
more people he gets thrown to the ground
people attack him with a skateboard
another person comes at him with a gun
one person he shoots that dies one
person he shoots gets harmed
but in both cases they're grabbing his
gun trying to pull it away from him
while one person is trying to shoot him
another person is trying to hit him
so after that happens he's still in
shock he runs towards the police
gives himself up they tell him to go
home and then he gets charged with
multiple counts of intentional homicide
and attempted intentional homicide
where they're trying to put him in
prison for life even though everybody
including the new york times who broke
down the video said
this is one of the cleanest clearest
cases of self-defense they've ever seen
i i actually missed that from the new
york times because most of the media
that i saw was just on
this kid's a white supremacist i mean
that's what it was he was a white
supremacist
in essence hunting down black people
even though it's all on video
all these false stories i mean this kid
comes from a family with family members
of multiple races
they did a deep dive on all of his
social media i mean they did a
colonoscopic
kind of review of his social media and
they found no connections of any form of
racism of any kind
no connections to militia of any kind no
connections to anybody like that of any
kind
no statements like that at any time all
they had was that he had once gone to a
trump rally
that was their sole basis the oh he went
he went to a trump rally like
exactly and he's a a gun supporter and
he's a a police military supporter
and that was it but they all they just
did the most the media ran with these
false allegations the stream of false
to this day they continue to tell false
stories the prosecutors continue to lie
about them
using court proceedings to get away with
the lie the kid's the most innocent
defendant i've ever represented
ever been involved with but the case
goes far past him if he gets convicted
uh self-defense is dead in america so
how worried are you in general
that the reality and the evidence of
cases like this
actually don't matter anymore and what
really matters is public opinion or
pressure put on by the mayor
or we saw you know that the city of
minneapolis paid out
i think it was 26 million dollars if i'm
not mistaken to george floyd's family
before
the verdict of the trial that that
really like the theater has far more to
do
with with what happens than the reality
of the case
what i've been uh taught what i teach a
lot of young lawyers is the court of
public opinion often matters a lot more
than the court of law
that you can lose a case in the court of
public opinion before you can ever
win it in the court of law and that was
what's critical in kyle's case
it was critical to to get all these
false there's a reason why prosecutors
keep lying about him in court over and
over again
it's because they know that those lies
will be repeated by the media
which will get back to the jury pool and
the judges and the politicians
which will all have some role in how
kyle's case is done
that's why you have to defend the u.s
supreme court said 40 years ago
a competent lawyer must defend his
client in the court of public opinion
and to actually be an effective
representative of his
of his client that's why the court of
public opinion is critical and that's
where a lot of people who think they may
be powerless
don't underestimate their own power
their participation in the court of
public opinion
ultimately shapes the outcome of these
cases when you talk to some of the
prosecutors like
off the record if you're having a
whiskey with one of these guys after i
mean do they realize how evil what
they're doing is or they just believe
it's just it's just part of the process
for some of them they actually believe
in it they're politically ambitious
politically aspirational they're people
who will just
do any they believe the ends justify the
means it's the whole sort of new left
the new left is not like your old
classical liberal who believed in the
process for its own sake
this new left believes the process is
ridiculous the process is solely there
to achieve a certain objective
and that's why they have no like
hypocrisy means nothing to them
unlike dante's you know bottom level of
hell they would you know in their level
of hell
hypocrisy takes you to heaven so it's a
whole different mindset and a lot of
them actually celebrate their misconduct
celebrate their malfeasance the ridden
house prosecutor is one of the most
unethical prosecutors i've ever
witnessed
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversation about law
instead of the non-stop yelling to get
everywhere else check out our
law playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell